so when you think about sailing camp for
kids you might think of sports like
archery or soccer or swimming maybe even
sailing but sailing can often feel out
of reach for many families especially in
communities of color this statistic
shocked me when i read it only .1 of the
country's sailing population is diverse
point one guys we hit the water to see
how one sailing camp in beautiful
vermont is trying to change that in a
state that has one of the least diverse
populations in the country
sometimes this thing swings over and you
have to duck right yeah the swing is
when you tackle
and that means when you like change
directions yes so you can change your
cores
siblings robert and mabel white are used
to charting their own course it will
just seem surprised
why do you think that's surprised
because the only black person that sails
[Music]
they're usually some of the only
minorities they see sailing on
shimmering lake champlain between
vermont and new york it's just a
refreshing feeling to have does it help
you clear your mind yeah
you both were like yeah the teams have
been sailing since they were six we're
making our sail catch wind right
now they're at a camp trying to change
the face of sailing
often seen as too white too expensive
elitist and historically exclusionary
we're undoing damage that has happened
in the sport
from there being a whites only sign on
the front door of a yacht club owen
milne is at the helm of burlington
vermont's community sailing center if
sailing is our middle name community is
our first name
to better live up to that first name
last year the center started providing
free sailing camp to kids from diverse
backgrounds in the burlington community
one rich with refugees and immigrants
from places like nepal and congo what
was the racial makeup of the camp
before this initiative and now we might
have had five or six kids for a full
summer kids of color and that was out of
500. and now wow
right
five or six out of 500 is not okay get
ready for us to sail we're on track to
hopefully get to 25 percent in the next
few years
and we think we can get there
to get there the camp began advertising
in seven different languages including
arabic somali and nepali to find more
camphors like adam almatory originally
from syria we get to kayak we get sail
for free and it's
very fun to just go out in the water i
used to be scared of water but now i can
just jump in right now
the idea for the camp to tackle its
diversity problem came after this
the national reckoning that followed the
murder of george floyd it's unfortunate
that it took an uprising for this to end
up on the front of our consciousness
um but the reality is we don't want it
to slip away so that's why we've made
this promise to these families that will
extend out decades
the goal is to reach as many kids as
possible not just so they can learn
their way on the water
but also the confidence and quick
thinking needed in life
donations allow diverse students like
finn schonstrom whose mother's mexican
and native american a free month of
sailing camp for four years straight
that usually costs almost seven thousand
dollars my mom told me like four weeks
four years i was like
you must be getting something wrong
that's crazy it's like and it's free
like yes of course i'll do it it sounded
too good to be true yeah
we actually make it promise to make it
free for life and then once they turn 15
they can work here as a junior
instructor and your participants can get
a job out of this at the end uh yeah why
not and we get uh great employees
where's the wind coming from and the
chance to help the sport spread its
sales it's nice to see other people are
like joining
other black people yeah so more kids of
color like can experience
the magic of being on the water yeah
it is pretty magical isn't it
[Music]
it was so magical and you know this is
about sailing but it's also just about
the fact that all kids need to be able
to access all things yeah and with
sailing in particular you know we talk
about the importance of nature but when
you're on the water it just kicks it up
a notch because you're in a completely
different atmosphere you're hearing the
water you're you're really like in the
moment because you have to be reacting
to all the elements and i think that
that's good for all of us i like what
owen says about understanding the need
for diversity in this sport and all
things by watching what happened a
couple of summers ago you know that's
the point sometimes just change a little
empathy that changes hearts and changes
minds yeah and just making sure that
whatever you want to do you have an
opportunity to do it i mean that's it's
clearing obstacles i i don't know
anything about sailing if if a captain
of a sailboat went down or a pilot went
down i'd be more likely to land the
plane than to get
back to the harbor as long as you can
tread water yeah
i would just be going where the wind
took me